[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
oh god
this is hard
all right
i just want to announce everybody that
kalila and i are no longer together
[Music]
it's been not over it's not over i'm in
the sense that
you know
we
i want to say that kalila is
the love of my life my best friend
um
if there was a book about my life she
would be
if there was ten chapters she'd be four
of them at least five of them give me
half maybe i'll give you half of it
yeah
today's monday july 18th and we have
some sad news in the kami world today
the tiger belly crew bobby lee and
kalila they've announced that they are
officially no longer dating the show
will go on as normal as host and co-host
but the two are no longer in a
relationship here's the good news
i i'm we're not stopping tiger belly
we're not um
we're good
we're good
we're not stopping um i'm never going to
see anybody else in my life i can't
really say i just know i just i have no
interest are you a priest
i have no interest i really have no
interest you know what i mean we just
need time to heal you don't know that
yeah anyway um
that's how i feel
and as always welcome back to the joke
world comedy update every single monday
bringing you the news that you need to
know from your favorite comedians your
favorite podcast new stand-up specials
the whole comedy world all in one place
summed up for you every monday so please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now turning on the post notifications so
you don't miss anything last week was a
little slow in the comedy world for news
but we usually have some great stuff in
these and we still have some great stuff
to talk about today this breakup comes
on the heels of all the brennan shob
drama they just went through which if
you don't know about that we have a
great video summing it all up for you
it's obviously very sad to see them
breaking up i mean we've seen them
together hosting this podcast for years
now i'm curious about so many things if
the podcast is going to be a little bit
awkward to start if there's going to be
any rekindle of this relationship if
kalila has to move out i mean what's the
living situation could they do tiger
belly from their house or from bobby's
house so how's that going to work i mean
there's a lot of questions to still be
answered you know what's changed though
i mean
we sleep on the same bed together he
doesn't want to let me go you guys yeah
yeah you think free bobby free me yeah
yeah
she's not leaving he's not leaving
i've literally been like i'm looking for
another place to live and he's like no
no
no no
he's not allowing me out no because it's
just you know what's changed to be
honest though it almost seems like there
was too much [ __ ] going on for them not
to break up and for them not to break up
publicly i mean think about it they had
the brennan shop and the h3 drama going
on then it comes out that bobby lee
might have been entertaining other women
during this relationship which leads to
them going to an open relationship which
leads to kalila seeing another guy in
hawaii you have stevie robbie's brother
calling her a gold digger you have the
internet tearing them apart everyone
weighing in from so many different
angles it makes sense that they need a
break they need to let this settle down
and they needed to break up that's just
too much to go through so essentially my
brother said some things to a random
person
that were not true
he has
to me personally
apologized i mean for me you know i mean
um
and i think he knows
his mistake but i don't know fully you
know i mean how he feels but um
essentially you know he said things like
you know kalila was a gold digger
conspiracy time
they might still be together dude how do
you not break up with all this going on
and the public just ridiculing your
relationship it kind of makes sense for
them to be like okay we're broken up
everyone gets off both their backs they
still host the show together give it a
year and then they get back together
we spent 24 hours
a day together
we created tiger belly together we have
other things that we want to do
we have seven animals we live together
her niece lives with us we're a family
and there's a you know a warmth in the
house and um it feels
like a family like i said but um
but it got to the point where it's like
what else if i'm not going to change
and i'm not you know and i trust me i
tried so it got to the point where i was
like
you know we threw out suggestions and
things that um you know
i was mindful about how
kalila can
maybe you know um
get her needs fulfilled right and i
threw out suggestions maybe you see
somebody else you know i mean
burke chrysler dropped a mega podcast
episode last week it had hints of the
old sober october days when you had four
great comedians all on mic drinking
busting each other's balls a big big
podcast episode although this one was
cool because it was on bert's tour bus
during the fully loaded festival there
was like a rain out at one of the venues
so they did a podcast with shane gillis
mark norman big j okerson brian simpson
chelsea lynn nicki glazer then obviously
bert hosting it and it was cool to see
them all on a bus and all these comics
drinking having a good time and doing
this big big big podcast for two hours
the content itself is interesting
because for me watching this i'm mostly
a fan of gillis and norman and big j and
bert kind of group right mostly new york
guys and then there were some la
comedians like nikki glazer in them in
there and the vibes you could just see
the different styles clashing the new
york guys being more raunchy joke
reliant just trying to do whatever's
funniest and then some of the la comics
trying to mix in some woke themes or
like preachy lessons it was it was
hilarious to see both these styles
clashing and just
what i think is way funnier which is
like norman and gillis um just kind of
almost making jokes between themselves
even with their eyes even if we don't
get to do a show tonight i had so much
fun today
and that slide it's nice that we get
this hang because i was kind of getting
sad because we have to leave at midnight
tonight as opposed to having a long hang
afterwards what are you laughing at god
what are you laughing at shane nothing
keep talking every time i start talking
a little too long he starts laughing and
it makes me self-conscious but i'm just
saying that i'm glad that we have a hang
now as opposed to a show i like to watch
the faces of people around her
when she's going
and what do you see in those faces shane
what do you observe and what makes you
giggle i see people's souls leaving
their [ __ ] bodies
i do this for a living shane it's really
insulting
there's also a moment in this where
nicki glazer apologizes to shane gillis
about some things she said on howard
stern about his snl firing which is like
very awkward to watch and also kind of
fun to watch it's not awkward at all i
don't think shane i'm sorry i brought it
up we can totally not talk about it
okay
what happened
um i just was i i was on stern and i
said like stupid [ __ ] about com
commenting on his snl thing and i didn't
expect to get asked about it and i just
said stuff i don't even know what i said
i wouldn't even want to revisit i was
embarrassed i'm embarrassed of what i
said and um i thought this is you and i
didn't know him
yeah so many people i've had like i'm
right and they're wrong and they don't
know what like you just get thanks mark
it's the last one i swear to god i mean
at least hit it on the microphone if
you're gonna do it i put it in
you don't consider how you could maybe
be wrong in the situation and can i tell
you what i'm let me just do an
experiment where what if i was wrong
what would that look like and then you
go oh it kind of sucked why are you
doing it again no
that's good can you film me farting by
the way
this was a huge podcast episode that
dropped so many big-name comedians all
in one episode
i told you the news is a little slow
this week the first night we watched it
and it was great
no dave and mans
and it was the first half of the movie
which is just shitty it's just jaguar
paul getting his life destroyed
and it was like holy [ __ ] i can't wait
to see this
we were so we're at the after party last
night like let's get the [ __ ] out of
here i know let's watch apocalypto this
is going to be great is that really the
name that's his name
well he's indigenous so i don't think
their names are funny but
okay
no don't worry i'll defend you
publicly i'll defend you you wouldn't
defend you
you'd go to the [ __ ] mattresses for
nikki i would be so excited to be like
fire her down
i deserve
i was so excited for a friend to be on
howard stern
the guest list is where we go through
who was on each other's podcasts the
previous week to make sure that you
don't miss any comedian appearing on any
show that you'd like to watch so to
start off we have maybe my favorite duo
my favorite combo in comedy we have
tomorrow on the joe rogan experience i
see this guy pull his dick out right
and what we learn is remember the guy
that said the thing and i'm like i hope
you die in a house fire yeah
the guy behind him was like
you don't [ __ ] with tom's show
he's on my side
he's like i got tom's back
and starts to piss on him and it ends up
pissing on a bunch of people
your mom's house had on andrew santino
this week another elite guest whiskey
ginger had on boo johnson flagrant had
two episodes last week of just the guys
which are usually the funniest episodes
when they go no guest and are just the
crew the joke world podcast we
interviewed nimish patel last week
christina p was on the honeydew with
ryan sickler this past weekend in theo
vaughn they had a big episode riff raff
was the guest last week which is always
hilarious him and theo look exactly the
same and then tiger belly has on chris
distefano for their first post-breakup
episode and in this last section we
cover any new specials that came out the
week before there was a moment in time
where there were tons of specials coming
out right when we started this every
single week we were talking about like
three new specials
that slowed down a little bit but we did
have a massive one drop yesterday andrew
schultz dropped his first ever
pay-per-view special on his website july
17th obviously we know the story now of
him buying his own special back to have
full creative freedom over the process
and over the material after already
selling it to a third-party streamer
so this is a big gamble that he took i
want to know what you guys thought of it
did you like the process the
pay-per-view process watching it on his
website did you go to the live show
after were you live tweeting able to
connect with other fans let me know if
this process worked if his gamble worked
if this is something that you want other
communities to do moving forward that's
it for this week in comedy make sure you
subscribe make sure you like do all that
youtube stuff i know every video you
watch there's someone being like like
and subscribe but
it'd be cool if you actually did it just
for me or do it for everyone but
specifically this time too um thank you
for watching again i'll see you next
week
because you can tell
[Music]
you